you'll never be anything but a criminal
to them which means you will never be a
hero hey youtubers this Charlie this
week on arrow we got to see Michael Jai
White for the first time his bronze
Tiger China white came back and Roy got
one step closer to becoming the red
arrow so let's do a super quick recap
then talk about what it means the title
of the episode was identity but it
mostly revolved around Oliver's internal
struggle between the killer he was last
year and the hero he's trying to be this
year the Roy gets arrested trying to
stop China white in the Triads from
stealing drugs that are being shipped to
the hospital in the glades Oliver finds
out that tries to stop it himself
and runs afoul of bronze tiger this
basically says so far two main plots
Oliver trying to stop China white and
two Roy trying to help the hood there's
also kind of like this third subplot
about Oliver and Felicity spending the
night together and three two one so Roy
gets his wish and Oliver masked as the
hood basically tells him that he's gonna
be part of the team now only he's gonna
be feeding Oliver Intel about what's
going on inside the glades instead of
actually karate chopping everyone he
sees he's more of a contractor on Team
arrow he's not full staff yet that
actually comes with a handy new leather
uniform and weapons during the in teaser
though Laurel gets the drop on Oliver in
police headquarters and it looks like he
might be unmasked but since as the
cliffhanger we won't find out till next
week so let's talk about the most
important parts one Laurel getting the
drop on Oliver
obviously I'm expecting him to pull
something out of his quiver to help him
escape I don't think that she'll end up
finding out who he is till the end of
the season but I do think it's going to
happen in this season I think he'll
unmask himself - Roy is on Team arrow
officially now he left the end of the
episode with that arrow in his back
pocket just meaning that he's basically
gonna be part of the shenanigans this
season good for him he's only part-time
though but Oliver is basically going to
get all of his big missions from things
based on what Roy tells him I'm also
guessing that by the end of the season
all of the corporate plots at the Summer
Glau plots the League of Assassins who
we haven't really seen on the show yet
and all the other criminals on the show
like the secret six are actually going
to come together by the end of the
season - so Roy will probably end up be
fighting for team arrow by the end of
the season if he's not full on red arrow
3 the island Slade in the love triangle
aside they found some really
weird-looking skulls in this cave and it
was whatever the people who had visited
the island we're looking
or that's going to deal a lot with a dr.
Ivo storyline he's actually part of the
island storylines so we won't find out
what's going on in there till future
episodes but remember he's actually the
person in DC Comics that created Amazo
so I'm guessing that these weird-looking
skulls were actually part of something
that's going to lead to Amazo or
Sebastian blood this is a bit of an
easter egg for DC Comics fans but even
though the characters called Sebastian
blood on the episode and he's just kind
of set up as like this real-world foil
for Oliver in the comic books there's a
character called Jason blood who's
actually bonded with the demon Etrigan
so it could be a reference to that
character but because demons on arrow is
just a little too far outside of the
realism that they're going for obviously
I don't expect him to turn into a demon
anytime soon so that's not who that
character is and lastly can we just
mention Oliver and Felicity in this
episode for a minute they were hilarious
I'm getting a little worried now because
she's being so wonderful in this
relationship of theirs that I have that
feeling that the League of Assassins are
the big bat or someone is just going to
do something terrible tour this season
it's always the most wonderful
characters that actually get dumped on
the most so I'm actually a little bit
afraid now but let me know if you agree
is something terrible going to happen to
Felicity this year next week Oliver is
actually going to be meeting Black
Canary for the first time and it doesn't
look like it's going to be love at first
sight be sure to subscribe to get that
video I'll be posting it right after the
episode airs tomorrow morning I'll be
posting my American Horror Story video
for him tonight to save a little extra
time to watch it if there's anything
that you thought was really important
that I didn't mention be sure to write
it in the comments and we'll discuss if
I as always if you really want to help
me out please like and share this video
in the meantime while you wait for that
American Horror Story video you can
click here for all my other arrow season
2 videos and you can click here for all
my other American Horror Story videos
from this season thanks so much for
watching see you guys tomorrow morning
high-five
you